moi je suis attachée au pacte
républicain et toutes celles et tous
ceux qui vont tagué qui vont insulté qui
vont agresser qui vont menacer la
république dans un sens comme dans
l'autre il abîme le saut républicain et
notre enjeu à nous c'est aujourd'hui de
montrer que la république elle doit être
forte que l'état de droit ce n'est pas
un état de croix c'est ça l'enjeu s'est
montré aujourd'hui qu'on peut changer
les choses dans le respect de la
démocratie
mais avec de la fermeté de la volonté
politique besoin que la mort de samuel
platine soit pas une mort pour rien de
plus mais qu au contraire aujourd'hui on
prenne le taureau par les cornes
donc oui il faut sept minutes de silence
il faut ce moment des changes aussi dans
la classe mais ensuite il faudra aller
plus loin et aller plus loin c'est
défendre le professeur c'est sortir du
pad vague où la hiérarchie a été trop
souvent tombés ces derniers temps c'est
ça allait plus loin mon objectif très
clairement il est de faire comprendre au
gouvernement la revue et surtout à la
majorité de la république en marche qui
déjà commencent à reculer en disant il
faut pas sur-réagir pas tomber dans la
culture d'émotion mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que comme d'habitude on ne
fait rien ça veut dire que comme
d'habitude on met la poussière sous le
tapis
je ne crois pas cela donc nous disons
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités
nous déposerons une proposition de loi
pour le 3 décembre il y aura un vote
tous les français pourront regarder ce
que chaque député votera et nous
poserons des conditions très claires
pourquoi parce que maintenant il faut
des actes et la stratégie du
gouvernement elle a échoué sur le tester
tracé isolé c'est un échec complet
parce que c'est la tap la stratégie du
temps de retard permanent moi ce que
j'ai dénoncé aujourd'hui c'est que le
gouvernement a toujours 15 jours de
retard sur les mesures à prendre et
juste un exemple très concret on nous
dit mais on n'a pas suffisamment de
personnel notamment de réanimateurs mais
pourquoi on a pas former davantage
d'aidés soignantes pour qu'elles
deviennent des infirmières que les
infirmières deviennent des médecins et
que surtout on puisse permettre à celles
et ceux qui avaient déjà eu des
formations de l'animateur d'avoir ces
formations de manière accélérée pourquoi
on ne l'a pas fait pourquoi on ne crée
pas d accorder aux éphémères en baisse
le drame il est qu'aujourd'hui un emploi
sur trois dans l'hôpital public en
france c'est un emploi administratif
c'est pas un emplois de soignants
ce que nous demandons c'est pas
simplement plus de personnel ce que nous
demandons c'est davantage de personnel
soignant du moi je n'accepte pas le
fatalisme aujourd'hui on n'a pas tiré
les leçons de la première vague et donc
le gouvernement un temps de retard
permanence et ce qui ramène au
couvre-feu et peut-être demain au
confinement locale